when the pandemic began and stocks
plunged most people likely expected that
the housing market was next in line but
with the fed lowering interest rates and
printing loads of money we've seen the
exact opposite unfold the median sale
price of a house in the u.s has
skyrocketed from 322 000 to 428 000
within a matter of two years this
translates to an annual growth rate of
13.2 percent which is literally higher
than the s p 500. this is of course
unsustainable and it has caused many to
speculate that a housing crash like
we've never seen is just around the
corner you just have to make one search
on youtube to see how prevalent this
theory really is and its popularity
isn't that surprising the fed is finally
starting to raise interest rates and the
housing market is finally starting to
show the first signs of a potential
slowdown there aren't this many bids on
each property and inventory is slowly
starting to build up not to mention the
stock market is teetering on bear market
territory so it only makes sense that
this pain extends to real estate right
well yes and in noah while it is likely
that we see a cooldown in real estate of
10 15 percent across the board and maybe
20 to 25 percent in some more heated
areas it's not likely that we see a 2008
stop 40-50 collapse with loads of
foreclosures and here's why
starting off the first thing to
understand is that a recession and the
stock market crash are not indicative of
a housing market crash in fact there's
plenty of recessions during which
housing continued to go up even during
the recession and this is especially
true during periods of high inflation
likely the best comparison that we have
today's market environment is the 1970s
when there was also a sky-high inflation
we saw inflation peak above 10 on
multiple occasions and it was until
interest rates were raised to over 10
percent that we finally saw inflation
cool down there were multiple recessions
during this time period that lasted for
multiple quarters each for example let's
take a look at the recession that took
place between 1974 and 1975. during this
time period the s p 500 got obliterated
dropping a full 50
but what do you think happened to
housing given this massive sell-off in
the stock market you would at least
expect a cooldown in real estate right
well the median sale price actually
increased from 34 000 to 39 000
in other words housing grew by 14.7
percent while the country experienced a
recession and the s p 500 dropped by 50
and this isn't a one-off thing either
this happened on multiple occasions
during this time period for instance we
saw another recession during the first
half of 1980. this recession was
accompanied by 20 sell-off in the stock
market but housing prices still went up
similarly in the 1981-1982 recession the
stock market sold off 25
this time the housing market actually
had a slight pullback coming in at 5.7
percent but nonetheless housing prices
were still higher at the end of the
recession than at the beginning of the
recession as you can see just because
there's a recession in the stock market
crashes does not mean that the housing
market must crash as well something else
to note is that a lot of people think
that the rate of increase in housing
prices are indicative of a housing crash
but this is not really true either
throughout the entire decade of the
1970s we saw abnormally high growth in
real estate prices when president nixon
dropped the gold standard in 1971 the
median sale price stood at twenty five
thousand eight hundred dollars ten years
later the median sale price sixty nine
thousand four hundred dollars this means
that housing prices grew 168
during these 10 years that translates to
an annual return of 10.4 for an entire
decade while that might be hard to
believe at first glance it makes perfect
sense when you account for inflation the
average inflation rate during these 10
years was a whopping 8.42
so really real estate only grew about
two percent per year during this time
period which is very sustainable the
thing to keep in mind is that real
estate is one of the most trusted and
reliable safe havens to protect against
inflation so it only makes sense that
real estate would at the very least keep
pace with inflation regardless of
whether there's a recession or stock
market crash so don't think that housing
prices have to come down just because
they've gone up so fast as long as
inflation is high that scenario remains
unlikely
another popular argument for a housing
market crash is rising interest rates
people argue that as interest rates go
up people will be able to afford less
meaning that sellers will have to
decrease prices while this argument
makes sense during normal periods the
thing to consider is that supply is
extraordinarily low
housing inventory is literally at
40-year lows and the trend has only been
downwards so it's not clear how much
rising interest rates will even affect
housing prices for example let's say
that 30-year mortgage rates go all the
way to eight percent from their lows of
about three percent the general rule is
that for every one percent increase in
mortgage rates purchasing power
decreases by roughly 10 percent so a
five percent increase in mortgage rates
would decrease purchasing power by 50
now that's quite a decrease but even if
this results in inventory doubling will
only be back to pre-pandemic levels in
other words the decrease in purchasing
power would more or less just wipe out
the excess demand so while houses may no
longer be selling for crazy amounts
above listing i'm not sure this would
drag down the listing prices themselves
all that much something else to note is
that even with these massive hikes
interest rates are still super low on a
historical basis and even more
importantly real mortgage rates are
still negative while a six percent
mortgage rate may sound high compared to
12 months ago six percent is still lower
than the eight percent inflation that
we've been seeing so from an investment
perspective taking out a mortgage right
now is still rather appealing and the
last thing to consider regarding
mortgage rates is that they're
completely irrelevant to a significant
amount of buyers because they're buying
with cash now this isn't to say that
they don't keep tabs on mortgage rates
but in terms of purchasing power it does
not affect them whatsoever i'm sure
these guys would like for the real
estate market to cool off as well so
that they can buy lower but most of them
are not going to wait for a crash
because they have excess cash reserves
that need protection from inflation i
mean these 13 companies alone hold a
trillion dollars in cash
now apple is likely not going to go out
and pick up single family homes but
banks and financial institutions will
and that's exactly what they've been
doing in q4 of 2021 for example almost
20 of all u.s home sales were to
institutional investors who are more
than likely paying cash so rising
mortgage rates probably won't cause a
housing market collapse and if you don't
believe me just take a look at the 1980s
after a decade of high inflation in the
1970s the fed decided to jack up
interest rates to unprecedented amounts
this caused 30-year mortgage rates to
nearly reach 20 percent
given that mortgage rates were at 8.5
just a few years before this this means
that mortgage rates rose 10 percent
according to a rule of thumb purchasing
power should have decreased by 100 and
housing prices should have gotten flamed
but in reality real estate prices
actually ended up rallying 100 percent
over the next decade so if an 18
mortgage rate did not cause a crash
there's no guarantee that a 78 mortgage
rate will
yet another factor thus preventing a
housing crash from taking place is that
home buyers are more qualified than ever
before here's the thing for 2008 cell
collapse to take place there needs to be
a fundamental crisis secular variations
in supply and demand due to mortgage
rates and inflation are not going to
crash the housing market 40 within 12
months for that you need a fundamental
crisis like loads of unqualified buyers
and low cash reserves across financial
institutions but we're not seeing that
we're actually seeing the exact opposite
the average home buyer is more qualified
than ever and the reason for this is
that the average person can no longer
afford these homes so it's primarily
just high-income families that are
buying homes in texas for example the
median home buyer has a household income
of a hundred and twelve thousand dollars
this puts the average home buyer in
texas in the 71 percent talent in terms
of household income in other words the
majority of homes are being sold to
people who are well off so it's quite
unlikely that we're going to see a
crisis where people suddenly can't pay
their mortgages now you might be saying
that these people may lose their jobs
during a recession which could change
their financial position but the truth
is the vast majority of job losses are
usually amongst everyday blue collar
workers white-collar workers are
generally some of the last people to
lose their jobs because of two reasons
one these employees are harder to
replace so companies are more reluctant
to let them go
and two most of these guys work at cash
with id companies that can afford to
weather a recession
also even if the company cannot survive
the recession it's more than likely that
the home buyer can survive it themselves
the median bank account balance rises
exponentially with income for example
the median banking balance in the us is
only 5 300
however the median bank on balance of
someone earning between 90 and 100 000
is 70 000
the median home buyer in texas actually
makes even more than this so it's likely
that they have nearly a hundred thousand
dollars in savings the median monthly
payment on a new mortgage was 1931 in
february
even if we say that's 2500 these median
home buyers could keep up their mortgage
payments for two full years before
running into problems also it's not just
home buyers who are on top of their
finances banks are on top of their
finances as well
jp morgan chase for example is holding
1.5 trillion dollars in cash and bank of
america has 895 billion in cash these
institutions and home buyers are more
liquidated than ever before meaning that
the odds of a fundamental crisis are
also lower than ever before
in the end there's no question that
housing is becoming increasingly
unaffordable for the average person but
this does not mean that the housing
market is going to collapse anytime soon
it appears that many people are hoping
for a massive plummet so that they can
finally buy for a reasonable price but
the truth is that 2008 was a one-off
thing i mean just take a look at the
last 60 years worth of pricing data
there are times where the market goes
sideways or cools off 10-15 percent but
2008 was the only time that the housing
market actually crashed since then
regulation has tightened significantly
and lenders have become extremely
cautious so it's primarily just
high-income families and cash buyers who
are driving the current market on top of
this from the 1970s and 80s we've seen
that real estate can continue to
skyrocket despite recessions stock
market crashes and interest rate hikes
now this isn't to say that we won't see
a cool off like we've already been
seeing
as mortgage rates rise and inventory
builds up the real estate market will no
doubt soften but to correlate that to a
full-on housing crash is quite a leap in
logic to be honest the vast majority of
articles and videos are telling people
that there's going to be a monumental
housing crash or just preying on these
people's desperateness to afford a house
but that's just what i think and i'm
just some random guy on the internet do
you guys think that there's going to be
a housing collapse comment that down
below
also drop a like if you hope that
inflation doesn't get much worse and of
course consider checking out our discord
community to suggest for your video
ideas and consider subscribing to see
more questions logically answered but
until then i'm hurry and i'll see you
guys on the next one
you